all right welcome back to las vegas now
all the couch and desk time
lately can really affect your posture
and you know what helps
yoga so grab your mats and do this with
me with brienne derosier
founder of mache is she's here to show
us how yoga can help us realign and
build better posture hey
hey that's right thank you so much for
having me thank you for joining us
to be here and talking about posture me
too
okay so i want everyone at home to
really you know interact with us right
now
get get on the floor you know sit indian
style right
so are we talking about specific yoga
poses today that can improve the posture
we are yeah so just to your point about
a lot of us
working either slumped on the couch or
over the desk right
on our devices so let's first talk about
ergonomics when it comes to how you sit
at the desk okay so i've made a little
makeshift desk here but we can just
have the imaginary desk for this
conversation okay but really what you're
looking for
is avoiding prolonged amounts of time in
this c
shape of the spine okay or some folks
even take that
too far over the screen as they're
slumping over the death
so the first step is to find that nice
plumb line so you can bring the body
forward and back until you feel that
balancing point right there in the
center where the joints are all stacked
i'm already feeling good
that are doing this with us by the way
so how can how can we easily
also turn our work spaces or wherever we
are whether it's a living room an office
how can we easily turn that
into a yoga space absolutely so the key
is to have reminders and my favorite
reminder
is to have my gear ready present
available
so that it's not hidden from view and it
reminds me
that i should move my body and change
the shape up a bit
so it's really important to have your
gear available
and easy to use but also sticky notes
can be a really
helpful tool to remind you to breathe
stretch the neck every couple minutes
lastly it's not a bad idea to set
reminders on your phone
that can ping you at regular intervals
that's beautiful that's a really that's
really great advice i will pretend i
bring my yoga mat to work every day
brienne let's get into a couple more
poses before we let you go sure thing
sure thing okay so when
you are back at your house a good way to
build strength in the core which helps
keep that good posture is to practice
plank pose
so plank pose you get on hands and knees
first
and then you extend one leg and then the
other by tucking the toes
and bringing the body into one full line
so here we want that stack to join again
so the shoulders are right over the
wrist beautiful
hold this for a couple breaths and when
you feel
like you're ready drop those knees back
down
and take a neutral spine and breathe so
this is really helpful to help build
that core strength
and maintain good posture thank you so
much we're going to have to wrap up how
can people get more information on mache
you're welcome please visit us at
www.heymache.com
or at hey mache on instagram and
facebook thank you so much
thank you thank you namaste
all right we'll be right back everybody